en este vídeo quiero hablarles acerca de
una sucesiones que son muy típicas en el
mundo de las sucesiones son las
sucesiones aritméticas las sucesiones
aritméticas y estas sesiones tienen una
peculiaridad la peculiaridad es que hay
un número fijo en la diferencia entre
cada uno de sus términos o dicho de otra
manera para pasar de un término a otro a
su siguiente termino hay un paso fijo y
después para pasar al siguiente vas a
tener que dar ese mismo paso ya sea una
cantidad negativa o una cantidad
positiva este paso o esta cantidad fija
es la que vas a tener que agregar
término a término por eso se les conoce
como sucesiones aritméticas y bueno la
pregunta de este vídeo es estas tres
sucesiones son aritméticas pues vamos a
ver a ver fijémonos en la primera de
menos 5 menos 3 hay más 2 de menos tres
menos uno también hay más dos de menos
uno a uno también hay más dos es decir
estamos sumando la misma cantidad
siempre por lo tanto es una sucesión
área
médica y ya que sabemos que sería médica
como la escribimos esta sucesión
bueno pues va a ser los genes los
términos yenes desde n igual a 1 hasta
infinito de en se cuenta que tenemos una
sucesión infinita con ella ahora vamos a
ver la primera forma de definirlo vamos
a definirla como una función explícita
que funciona explícita tengo a n es
igual a primero nos fijamos en el
término inicial el término inicial es
menos 5 y después nos fijamos en la
razón las razones cuanto estamos sumando
de término en término es más 2 más 2 más
2 por lo tanto la razón es 2 entonces va
a ser el término inicial más la razón y
a la razón hay que multiplicar la es
decir a este 2 hay que multiplicarlo por
n
1 porque date cuenta que para llegar al
término 2 tuvimos que sumar una vez la
razón para llegar al término 3 tuvimos
que sumar dos veces la razón y así
sucesivamente ahora recuerda que también
hay otra forma de escribir estas
sucesiones en su forma recursiva así que
vamos a hacerlo a uno el término
es igual a menos 5 y después el término
n es igual al término anterior es decir
al termino n1n1 más la razón que no es 3
es 2 quiero ver si me están poniendo
atención es perfecto para n mayor o
igual a 2 es decir como ya tenemos
definido el primer término
entonces los siguientes términos los
sacamos a partir de en mayor o igual a 2
y aquí ya tenemos las dos formas de
poder expresar esta sucesión de una
forma explícita o de una forma recursiva
ahora vamos a fijarnos en la segunda
acaso será esta una sucesión aritmética
pues vamos a revisar la de 100 a 107 7
de 107 a 114 7 de 114 a 121 también 7
perfecto por lo tanto podemos concluir
que como estamos sumando el mismo
término también va a ser una sucesión
aritmética perfecto y ahora vamos a
escribir esta sucesión en sus dos formas
la primera es que tenemos la sucesión de
a n desde n igual a 1 este infinito
dehaene y vamos a escribirlo en su forma
explícita el término inicial más
la razón y ya eso hay que multiplicarlo
por n
uno recuerda que estamos sumando la
razón n 1 veces para llegar al término n
por eso tiene tanta lógica esta
expresión porque esta expresión tiene la
idea de sumarle al término inicial la
razón multiplicada en a menos 1 veces
para sacar así el término n y ya con
esto tenemos la primera forma de
escribir una sucesión en su forma
explícita si yo lo que quiero es
escribir esta obsesión en su forma
recursiva pues tendremos que poner es la
sucesión de los términos
desde n igual a 1 hasta infinito con con
y ahora sí vamos a escribirlo en su
forma recursiva el primer término es el
término inicial que es 100 y después el
término n quienes recuerda que para
escribirlo en su forma recursiva hay que
escribir este término como función de
sus términos anteriores por lo tanto me
va a quedar el término anterior que es a
en m17 y perfecto ya tengo que ésta
también es una sucesión aritmética y ya
tengo también sus dos formas de
escribirlo y de hecho lo puedo
generalizar una sucesión aritmética como
se ve pues es una sucesión
en igual de infinito y bueno si lo
quisiera escribir de su forma explícita
me quedaría que a n es igual al término
inicial ojo este de aquí es su término
inicial más la razón
la razón es lo que le sumamos o lo que
le restamos podría ser que la sucesión
sea creciente o que sea decreciente
depende de qué signo tenga la razón ya
esto hay que multiplicarlo por n
1 eso es para verlo en su forma
explícita ahora bien si lo que queremos
también es escribirlo en su forma
recursiva lo que habría que hacer es
anidar los términos por lo tanto vamos a
ponerlo también aquí en su forma
generalizada como aquí que tenemos la
función explícita ya generalizada
entonces para generalizar la forma de
cursiva lo primero que hay que fijarnos
es en el término inicial que vamos a
suponer que vale acá y después el
término n va a ser igual al término
anterior es decir aa n menos 1 más la
razón y recuerda no vais olvidar que
esto es para n mayor o igual a 2 por lo
tanto ya tenemos las dos formas de
expresar una sucesión aritmética ahora
la pregunta es esta tercera sucesión es
una sucesión aritmética
pues vamos a ver de 1 a 3 hay dos
unidades de distancia de 3 a 6 hay 3
unidades de distancia y desde aquí hay
algo raro y de 6 a 10 hay cuatro
unidades de distancia por lo tanto como
no es el mismo número no es la misma
razón esta sucesión podemos concluir que
no sería métrica porque no sumamos
siempre la misma razón sea positiva o
sea negativa es decir no hay un número
fijo o un paso fijo entre sus términos y
bueno acaso habrá forma de escribir esta
sucesión ya sea en forma recursiva o en
forma explícita pues vamos a intentar
escribirla en forma recursiva entonces
nos quedaría que está sucesión es la
sucesión
desde n igual a 1 hasta infinito con y
vamos a encontrar la regla de
recursividad primero hay que definir el
término inicial que en este caso es uno
y después fijémonos qué es lo que pasa
con el término a en en jaén es lo mismo
que el término anterior más dos y
después es más tres y después es más
cuatro es decir nos fijamos en el
término anterior y le sumamos el
subíndice es decir lo que vamos a hacer
es
en el tercer término es lo mismo que el
término anterior que era 3 + 3 lo cual
es el subíndice y claro recuerda que
estamos hablando para n mayor o igual a
2 porque ya definimos el primer término
ahora lo que quiero que te des cuenta es
que una sucesión aritmética siempre le
sumamos la misma cantidad pero en este
caso n puede tomar valores distintos
aquí como está variando también n
podemos concluir que esta no es una
sucesión aritmética